مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره
[موسيقى]
برشلونه تعثر امام مايوركا 2- يعطي فرصه
لريال مدريد اليوم امام الاسباني مره
ثانيه بعد ما كان هو خطف منه الصداره
بالاسبوع الماضي
طبعا كالعاده بيتعازموا على الصداره اي
واحد بيكون عنده فرصه انه يبعد شوي عن
المنافس بيتعاطف معه وبيتعثر بيتعادل
بيخسر وبيخليه او بيعطيه الفرصه لارجع
يتصدر مره ثانيه اللي صار امبارح ببساطه
انه تشافي عمل كوارث حقيقيه مع برشلونه
بدايه من خط الدفاع اللي كل مباراه بيتبدل
من بدايه الموسم لحد الان تشافي ما لعب
على خط دفاع واضح مبارياتين ورا بعض بكل
مباراه لاعب لاعبين ثلاث لاعبين بيتغيروا
بالفريق وهذا امر بيخلق حاله من عدم
الاستقرار واللي زاد الطين امبارح انه
لاعب بمدافعين اثنين اول مره بيلعب مع بعض
مشكله الدفاع ما وقفت هون انه كان عنا
مشكله اهم وما حدا انتبه لها او ما حدا
حكى عنا هي مشكله او
هجوميا ممتاز ويسجل اهداف وريمونتات وقصص
حلوه كثير وممتعه والجمهور بحبوا وبحب
ادائه بالملعب ولكن جواه في الاكس دفاعيا
صفر ولا شيء لا بالتمركز لا بالتغطيه ولا
باي شيء هو دفاعيا سيء مش من اهم ميزاته
انه يكون مدافع جيد
هجوميا مبارح كمان كان سيء تمريراته غلط
بيخسر الاستحواذ او غسل الاستحواذ ثلاث
مرات هجوميا ما كان له اي تاثير على الجهه
اليمنى وهذا امر اثر بشكل كثير كبير على
برشلونه بالحاله الهجوميه امبارح اللي كان
عم يلعب حرفيا بدون ظهير يمين لما قرر يحل
الموضوع بعد ما كانت النتيجه صارت تقدم
مايوركا وبعدين برشلونه رجع فات قال لك لا
لازم نتدارك الموقف والنتيجه اثنين اثنين
فقام شال مارتينيز ونزل طيب سؤال على مدار
موسم ونص
كظهير يمين وكان عم يلعب بكون جنبه وجنبه
كريستينسن وعلى اليسار بالدي امبارح لما
شفت كانسيلو سيء هجوميا مش مستفيد منه
هجوميا من بين الشوطين مش عم يعطيك
الاضافه مش عم يعمل ربط مناسب مع الجناح
اليمين ومش عم يقدم لك اي يعني اضافه
هجوميه ليش بتخليه بالملعب لنهايه
المباراه ليش ما اخذت القرار انك تطلع
كانسيلو وتنزل كودة وتحول اراوخه لظهير
يمين وتلعب بكون مرتينز اساسا ما كان لازم
يلعب اساسي امبارح كان لازم ينزل
بكريستانسن لانه كريستان متفاهم مع اراوخه
وصار عنده خبره افضل من ايجو مارتينيز مع
برشلونه
وبمباراه صعبه على ملعب مايويورك خلصنا من
خط الدفاع واخطاء خط الدفاع الساذجه اللي
طبعا كمان لازم نحكي عن الخطا اللي صار
بالهدف الثاني واللي هو خطا وصفه شادي
بانه صبياني وهو حقا خطا صبياني لما يكون
عندك مدافعين واحد منهم ماسك المهاجم ومش
قادر يغطي عليه وتمركزهم غلط وتاركين
بينهم المساحه استغل المهاجم بسبب كره
طوليه من حارس المرمى حطها براسه لاعب
مايوركا وراحت للمهاجم اللي سجل الهدف
والمدافعين عم يتفرجوا لانه تركزون غلط
بطيئين بالتعامل رده فعلهم غلط مش متابعين
الكره بالشكل المناسب وهذا خطا لو صار
بدوره ثاني كان ممكن يتحول لترول والناس
كلها تصير تحكي عنه وتقول شوف هالدوري
ومستويات تعبان دفاع برشلونه هذا الموسم
تلقى لحد الان ثمانيه اهداف من سبع
مباريات بالموسم الماضي 25 مباراه
لبرشلونه تلقى 8 اهداف هذا الكلام خطير
جدا على دفاع برشلونه وهذا بيثبت انه
الدفاع برشلونه هذا الموسم بقمه السوق
بعكس الموسم الماضي اللي هو كان في دفاع
برشلونه هو نقطه القوه الرئيسيه بالانتقال
لنصف الملعب نص الملعب حرفيا كان في لاعب
واحد امبارح هو بس لعب واحد قابي اوريون
روميو سيء جدا كان سيء بالربط كان مع حارس
المرمى بالهدف الاول مع تر شتيغن ما فهم
عليه والكره بدها تيجي وطبعا الخطا على
تير شتيغن هون ما راح نلبسه ولكن روميه
وبيتحمل جزء من الخطا وروميو امبارح خسر
كل الكرات الهوائيه مع لاعبين مايوركا
وبنص الملعب ما كان يسترجع اي قرى بدون
خطا وبالحاله الهجوميه ما كان يقدم اي
اضافه هجوميه فقابي هو اللي كان يلعب دور
السي دي ام بعد ما طلع روميه هو اللي يغطي
على لاعبين مايوركا ويفوت معهم
بالالتحامات هوائيه مع انه اكثر منهم
بكثير وكان ينقل الكره للثلث الامامي وكان
يحاول انه يساند هجوميا ويصنع لقب ويضغط
على حامل الكره يعني مبارح كان خط وسط
لحاله ببرشلونه الاخ قندوقان يعني ما حدا
عارف شو دور بالمراه من بدايه الموسم
لليوم جمهور برشلونه مش عارف ايش موجود
يعني هل هو بركه مثلا بالملعب هل هو داخلي
يحفز اللاعبين معنويا مثلا ما حدا بيعرف
شو شو ساب وجوده لا هو عم يضيف هجوميا ولا
هو عبسان الدفاعيا ولا هو اللاعب السريع
بطيء وما له حيل يلعب وبالارتداد الدفاعي
بطيء وبالارتداد الهجومي ما له نفس يلعب
جاندوغان جاي مع برشلونه يعني جاي يخلص بس
يختم مش جاي يقدم اداء
وهذا امر عبيد يضر وسط برشلونه بشكل كبير
بشكل كبير برشلونه دائما منقوص لاعب لما
كاندوغان بيلعب اساسي بالحاله الهجوميه
طبعا لما تشابه يقرر انه يعمل تبديلات
هجوم برشلونه مبارح كان جيد بالمناسبه
وكان الاكس جي تبعه تقريبا وهو افضل اكس
جي لما برشلونه بيلعب امام فريق بيلعب
بخمسه مدافعين هذا الموسم هو طبعا الاكسبك
او الاهداف المتوقعه وهذا بيعني انه
برشلونه صنع فرص محققه للتسجيل ولكن اهدر
هاي الفرص وخصوصا بعد هدف رافينيا لانه
شفنا فيران توريس ضيع عن فرات شفنا جوا
فليكس انفراد وكره خطيره بالعارضه طبعا ما
كان محظوظ فيها شفنا كثير لاعبين ضيعوا
فرص سهله جدا لتسجيل الاهداف وهي كانت
نقطه فارقه بالمباراه ولكن لما تشافي قرر
ان يعمل تبديل مين قرر يطلع قرر يطلع
شو احسن لاعب كان بالمنظومه الهجوميه
لبرشلونه هو رافينيا
طيب اساسا من البدايه ليش يبدا بفران
توريس ايمتى فيران تورس لعب كراس حربي
صريح مع برشلونه وكان فعال ولا مره ولما
قرر يطلعه بدقيقه 60 طيب ليش مستني عليه
للستين مكان فيك تبدل بين الشوطين وتنزل
ليفاندوفسكي وتغير مسار المباراه ولما قرر
ينزل لمين يامال قرر يطلع جوافه هو اللاعب
اللي قادر يصنع لك فرص هو اللاعب اللي
قادر الريمونتادا بمباراه سيلتا فيغو هو
اللاعب الاخطر بهجوم برشلونه خليت رفينيا
رافينيا على راسه عيني صنع هدف وسجل هدف
ولكن رافينيا غير هاي المساهمات بالمباراه
كان سيء سيء جدا هجوميا
فطلع رافينيا نزل شو اسمه يمان خلي جوا
فليكس مع ليفاندوفسكي واعمال ربط بينهم
والامور بتكون تمام لا يقرر انه يكون له
رؤيه ثانيه للمباراه وهاي كانت النتيجه
تعادل وتعثر بالنهايه كلام اخير او نقطه
اخيره عن
بهاي الطريقه وبهذا الاسلوب وبهاي الاخطاء
بالقدمين
يمكن انه يستمر مع برشلونه فتره اطول من
هيك مع انه بالتصديات هو من افضل حراس
العالم ولكن على مدار السنوات الماضيه كان
نقطه ضعف برشلونه هو انه ما بيعرف يلعب
بقدمه وامبارح شفنا الخطا اللي ارتكبه
وراح يرتكب غيره كثير لانه
سيء جدا وهي مفارقه انه برشلونه فريق
اتيكيتاكا فريق الاستحواذ عنده حارس ما
بيعرف يلعب اجري بالنهايه هاي كانت النظره
حول مباراه برشلونه ومايوركا تشافي لازم
يغير كثير بافكاره وخصوصا بالحاله
الدفاعيه
وبطريقه قراءته للمباراه والتبديلات اللي
بيعملها لحتى برشلونه يقدر انه يكمل
بالمنافسه على لقب الليغا هذا الموسم هذا
كان كل شيء بحلقه لون بعض الصافي حتى
نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل كونوا بالف خير